our series of more perfect union aims to
show show us that what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us this morning we introduced
you to a group of families first brought
together by the unique bond their
children share now they all share a
special tradition and learner shows us
it's as meaningful to these parents as
it is for their kids and a good morning
good morning well how is it that 10 kids
from 7 families in five states across
the country have one common bond we met
up with them all in Austin Texas for
they're not so traditional family
reunion
the tykes from Texas and the Liao's from
California are prepping for their annual
reunion but in this family none of the
adults are related it's the kids who are
all half brothers or sisters all ten are
genetically related and have a special
nickname I'll usually say it were going
to the Dibley reunion and what dib wings
or donor siblings because their parents
strangers originally all chose the same
sperm donor a man single mom Tara
Goldstein selected because she says I
wanted something with height and I also
wanted someone really good at math
because that's not one of my strongest
skill set
Goldstein gave birth to Mali in 2012 but
soon realized her daughter would have no
siblings she was gonna be an only child
and that made me a little sad I knew
that there was an opportunity to find
some blood relatives I didn't want to
deny her that opportunity then she
visited the donor sibling registry a web
site where parents can share information
about their donors and found her
daughter had half siblings around the
country this extended family now
includes two families from New York one
from New Jersey two families from Texas
one in Colorado and one in California it
began slowly like exchanging pictures
and seeing how much the kids looked
alike and it was just it was uncanny now
the parents bring their ten children in
ages ranging
from three to five together every year
and so do you see things your kids - the
other kids you go oh that's so similar
oh yeah personality traits Tom you see
some of them are so different but
there's so much the same jamie-lynn
Sergey says that natural kinship has
been crucial for her five-year-old son
Michael who has autism he doesn't always
connect well with other kids he's the
brightest little boy in the world but he
just has that connection issue yet he
found an immediate connection with his
half-brother from across the country
look five-year-old Mason that's a
brother bond that's not a friend on
so what's it done for the two of you to
have this it definitely gives you a
peace of mind anything he has towards
maybe having two moms or going you know
without a dad he'll have these other
nine children to have his back today the
bond has become more than biological for
families who started off separated but
became one tell me what you liked about
seeing each other every year it's great
why I just feel that it's really
important for families like ours to kind
of be proud of what we've done it's not
perfect but it's love well the donor
sibling registry that the families used
to connect has more than 60,000 members
and now these siblings have an open
donor which means when they turn 18 they
can contact him he has said if they
choose and at that point he may find out
that there's a whole family group linked
to him oh he's quite fertile mr. Mann
but I love the thing dib wings I love
that the sentiment of that she said it
may not be typical but it is love it's a
different kind of family this is very
nice I believe they made a movie on a
similar concept this is yes Ben smart
yes yes
it's working somebody mental didn't
shoot IANA cos I really did say thank
you thank you very much Janice cuz we're
all like huh